mein Thema heute Abend die maskenpflicht
bei Flugreisen endet europaweit
eigentlich ist es eine großartige
Neuigkeit besonders für Menschen wie
mich die nicht so gerne Maske tragen ab
Montag kann wenn es nach der EU geht auf
das Maske tragen verzichtet werden im
Flugzeug aber Deutschland geht
selbstverständlich mal wieder erneut den
Sonderweg und sieht weiterhin das Maske
tragenden Flugzeugen vor danach richte
sich auch die Lufthansa erklärte eine
Sprecherin der Tagesschau die Lufthansa
will also warten bis dies in deutsches
Recht umgesetzt wird ich frage mich ja
schon seit längerem hat die Politik die
maskenpflicht im Flugzeug und im
öffentlichen Personennahverkehr einfach
vergessen der deutsche corona-sonderweg
muss endlich enden mit dem Thema möchte
ich die Runde eröffnen und direkt die
Frage an Herrn Professor und gomery
geben teilen sie denn meine Einschätzung
meinem finden oder verstehen sie das
Deutschland die maskenpflicht immer noch
hat im Flugzeug und in der Bahn nein
nicht talliere Auffassung überhaupt
nicht ich finde sie unsolidarisch ich
finde sie auch unhöflich weil ich finde
sein Akt der Höflichkeit dass ich dann
wenn jemand neben mir sitzt die
ja ich hätte auch kein Problem hier im
Haus gilt ja eine maskenpflicht also wir
können die auch bei der Sendung haben
wenn sie wollen sie finden
Reserve noch weil ich finde die
maskenpflicht ist ein Ausdruck von
Höflichkeit von Kurzwort sie gegenüber
meinem Nachbarn und sie ist das nach wie
vor sinnvollste und beste Mittel um
Infektionen zu verhindern
viele Leute sich nicht impfen lassen
wollen ja das sage ich nicht nur das
sagen Ihnen auch alle Leute nicht alle
naja lassen
inzwischen die dass wir uns den
Meinungen von einigen wenigen nein nein
das sind nicht wenige international
widersprechen Ihnen auch Leute sagen Sie
doch mal wie viele haben sich angesteckt
oder infizieren sich in öffentlichen
Nahverkehr und im Flugzeugen da sind mit
Zahlen auf den Tisch da gibt's nämlich
Untersuchungen die verzweigen sie in
Deutschland aber sie wissen dass bei
einer insgesamt etwa fünf bis sechs
tägigen Inkubationszeit sie überhaupt
nie nachweisen kann auch können ob die
Infektion und direkt in einem Gottes
können doch das Screening schaffen
erzählen Sie doch keine mehr hinter die
Maske wird doch langsam zum Symbol der
deutschen Angst und also ich bin sehr
starken Austausch mit der
aerosolforschern Herrn Professor Köhler
und da kann man wunderbar die
diskutieren ob mir über zehn Prozent
Schutz sprechen 20 Prozent aber die
Frage ist doch vor was wollen wir uns
schützen ich meine verzweifeln ja auch
nicht an dass ein Helm vor
Kopfverletzungen schützt tragen wir
jetzt Helme also die Frage wie ist denn
die Betreuung na gut
da will ich einfach erstmal wissen wie
überhaupt die Zahlen sind und die
Bundesregierung verweigert sich der
Evaluation wie sinnvoll die Sachen sind
und die und was mir völlig fehlt völlig
fehlt von Anfang an ist die die
Ermittlung der Nebenwirkungen was von
Maßnahmen Medizin hat immer auch
Nebenwirkungen wenn ich mir die Schulen
anschaue
wenn ich mir die Infektion digital
deutet war entwickeln unter diesen Rotz
fahren die sie da tragen wenn ich mir
die ganzen Nebenwirkungen anschauen
würde glaube ich nicht dass wir zu einer
sinnvollen maskenpflicht zurückkehren
werden und ich finde das Wort
Solidarität in dem zusammen
überstrapaziert muss ich wirklich sagen
man muss natürlich sagen zu dem ganzen
Thema Luftverkehr haben wir ja eine
europäische Überlagerung auch ein
passend heute haben übrigens die
europäischen zuständigen Einrichtungen
entschieden dass sie sagen die Pflicht
zum Tragen einer Maske in Flugzeugen
sollte abgeschafft werden finde ich
übrigens auch nur sinnvoll dass man es
europaweit einheitlich regelt weil das
ergibt ja keinen Sinn in
irgendein anderes machen es ist jetzt
heute erst die Entscheidung gekommen
dass man sozusagen empfiehlt auf EU eben
dass die maskenpflicht fällt ersetzt
wird durch eine Empfehlung das finde ich
auch total okay dann kann Hermann
gommery weiter seine Maske tragen ich
würde den Flieger wahrscheinlich auch
machen aber am Ende finde ich schon
richtig dass man jetzt im Prinzip beim
öffentlichen nah mehr und beim Flieger
gleich zieht zudem wie es ja jetzt auch
entschieden haben auf eigene
Verantwortung
der deutsche Untertan macht alles gern
mit seit einiger Zeit braucht man nicht
mehr im Supermarkt lassen Sie mich
ausreden ja der super ob du noch gar
nicht
weil
so also Sie haben es ist so obwohl die
Pflicht viel bin ich in meinen
Supermarkt gegangen und der gute
deutsche trug weiterhin die Maske und es
hat sich in keinem ich bin sehr viel im
Ausland unterwegs es gibt einen USA
Staaten die ich besuche da trägt kein
einziger eine Maske im Florida wo ich
ein zweites Zuhause habe dann lachen die
Leute alle bei mir ganz schöne ganz
schöne Infektionszahlen
Freunde
kommen
machen was sie tun ja wir brauchen keine
Ratschläge aber es ist natürlich so dass
wir ein Volk sind das gern aufwach
Wanderer aufpasst ich habe noch irgendwo
erlebt dass du gezischt wird drei Meter
entfernt
Mentalität die so klassisch deutsch ist
die geht mir auf den Senkel und damals
mit verbrochen
sich rechtfertigen müssen jetzt haben
das mache ich gerne okay ich möchte
gerne
darf ich mal ungern auf jeden Fall das
Problem
was wir haben ist dass wir wenn eine
gesamt corona-krise nicht die Experten
die im Fach sind gefragt haben sollen
sie über die gleichen die sich so als
universalexperten geben wenn man sie mit
den aerosolf
werde ich wohl meinen ja da muss man
auch einen Drosten in Herr Lauterbach
und so weiter wenn man die zum Beispiel
Köhler schaue ich meine die zuhört die
machen Forschungen an kunstköpfen und so
weiter wir haben ganz klar gesagt das
wird übertragen über Aerosole die stehen
Raum in niedrigen engen Räumen Fahrstuhl
zum Beispiel darf man aber wieder die
Tür nicht öffnen wegen
Feuerschutzgründen aber die wirksamste
Maßnahme ist tatsächlich eine Lüftung
eine Lüftungsanlage die haben Vorschläge
gemacht im Bundestag vorgelegt keine
Resonanz passiert nichts die Maske hat
einfach die Nebenwirkungen die sind
nicht da kümmert sich keiner Drums
werden keine Messungen gemacht wie sie
die Sauerstoffknappheit aus bei Kindern
ich habe viele Kinder gesehen die haben
Konzentrationsprobleme Kopfschmerzen
also hier kommen von der Maske ja
doch zu Herr Scheuch hat am Anfang bei
seiner aerosolenforschung sich intensiv
für Masken ausgesprochen Herr Scheuch
war nie ein Gegner der Maske also wir
wollen die Leute richtig zitieren
zweitens wir haben rechts sie haben sie
mir nicht Lüftung wäre besser aber da wo
keine Lüftung ist ja warum jetzt gemacht
ja das ist eine gute Frage da bin ich
auch bei ihnen aber das hat nichts mit
der Masken gewesen solange wir keine
vernünftigen Lüftung haben solange wir
in den Schulen versäumen dort anständ
immer noch mit Maske die ganze Zeit in
der Schule sind Stunden
Frankreich das kann man durchaus bei
Kindern auch anders sehen aber in
öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln da wo wir
auch untereinander uns anstecken können
wir wollen als Ärzte nach wie vor
möglichst jede Infektion verhindern
wir haben momentan wunderbare
Umgebungsbedingungen die die der Sommer
kommt wir haben viel weniger Infektionen
wir können ja heute mit einer
Infektionsrate von über 500 sehr viel
besser leben als wir vor zwei Jahren mit
150 kg kommt doch gar nicht auf die
Definition es ist eine Frage von
Höflichkeit dass ich versuche meine
Umgebung zu schützen wenn ich selber
infiziert bin
immer persönlich sie gehen nicht auf
andere Argumente ein wieso bin ich jetzt
persönlich nein sie haben diejenigen die
keine Maske brauchen die vielleicht
einen Grund haben als die Ursache mit
Corona begann haben diese Herren hier am
Ton und Co und Merkel die Mutti und so
haben gesagt die haben die Masken sind
wir schon schleudern ich sehe die
Schlagzeilen habe aber
leider
Spiel was dadurch gezogen wurde deswegen
sind viele auch so unsicher muss ich
Ihnen sagen und deswegen bin ich
persönlich sie sind
persönlich
ich halte das für außerordentliche hoch
solidarisch und haben Ihnen die
maskenpflicht vor Ort
solidarisch das macht
trotzdem krank also wir können nach zwei
Jahren Geschichten erzählt haben zwei
Jahren kann man nicht einfach hergehen
und sagen wir brauchen die Masken weil
die Schützen ich will endlich mal Zahlen
haben wie viel das ist in Prozent ja und
zwar nicht nur Infektion auf die kommt
doch gar nicht an ist doch nicht
schweren Verläufe eine Todesfälle und
diese Zahlen haben wir nicht und wir
haben keine Forschungsunternehmen und
deswegen finde das Argument Maske ist
Solidarität finde ich ein moralistisches
Argument was in gutem böse unterscheiden
sollte und da müssen wir endlich mal weg
davon ich weiß jetzt nicht ob wir
wirklich noch mal noch mal die Zahlen
durch hervorholen sollen sie wissen ganz
genau dass die einzige Maßnahmen die in
der ersten und in der zweiten Welle
wirklich geholfen haben waren die
kontaktbeschränkungen eine der
einfachsten kontaktbeschränkungen die es
überhaupt gibt ist das Tragen von Masken
also wer sich heute hinstellt und
behauptet das wirkt alles überhaupt
nicht dem kann ich ehrlich gesagt nicht
ganz ehrlich
sagen
kontaktbeschränkung haben sie mir nicht
zu viel einfachste davon dass die Maske
sind das effektivste Mittel um in den
Infektionen nachher wenn Sie mit den
Leuten die sich auskennen sprechen dann
dann diskutieren die ob die ein wir ob
man nur Virenschutz hat von 10 20 30
Prozent die Frage ist die Relation wie
wie groß ist die Gefahr mein Beispiel
mit einem Helm tragen hat das drauf
angespielt und ich möchte wissen ob
diese 20 Prozent überhaupt notwendig
sind das wäre medizinische Situationen
haben wo mir eine Maske brauchen im
Krankenhaus immunsuppressionen und so
weiter ist doch selbstverständlich aber
in der Öffentlichkeit finde ich das
zunehmend eine ein Symbol einer
Irrationalität ich will endlich eine
rationale Diskussion haben über über
Nutzen und Schaden und dann können wir
diskutieren ob sie sinnvoll ist aber als
einfach sozusagen das ist zeigen von
Solidarität finde ich inakzeptabel nach
zwei Jahren wirklich es gibt im Jahr mal
im Journal of the American America
sociation ausreichend arbeiten die
belegen dass das Tragen einer Maske das
Infektionsrisiko um 85% senkt also ich
weiß gar nicht wir müssen mal lesen und
dann jetzt gestern kam das Frauen haben
naja das ist eine große Frage die WHO
hat Übersterblichkeit gemessen das ist
ein statistisches Phänomen was die
Mortalität
angeht an an gaskopf 2 sind wir deutlich
besser als Schweden wir haben aber
wahrscheinlich in derselben Zeit durch
die Schließung von Krankenhäusern etc
viele Operationen nicht gemacht wir
haben viele andere Dinge nicht gemacht
sodass wir statistisch nach den
Statistiken der wir oben in der
überstaatlichkeit da kommen aber unterm
Strich hat das eventuell gar nichts mit
Kuri zu tun
ja andere Operation abgesagt haben
ja das ist die große Verantwortung
auch hier in Berlin da diese Märchen von
den überquellen die Intensivstationen
das ist doch alles Teil der Angst mache
Teil der Übersterblichkeit wenn wir
jetzt mal nein aber das
ist dass die Krankheit so gravierend ist
wie Übersterblichkeit überhaupt nicht
gegeben es ist heute in die WHO-Studie
die heute veröffentlicht wurde ich habe
diese Frankfurter allgemein natürlich
ich bin alter Mann ich
lesezeitung dafür steht da die Wahrheit
drin so und wenn ich die NZZ lese stelle
ich fest dass eben diese bemessungsdaten
die angelegt werden und die selbst oder
den Fachleuten wie er guck mal hier ohne
Frage einer ist sehr umstritten deswegen
möchte ich auch sagen ich bin wieder
Arzt noch Virologe aber ich bin Bürger
und Steuerzahler und beobachte diese
gesamte Kampagne und fühle mich total
verkohlt ich bin vom ersten Tag an
belogen worden durch die Politik und
durch Leute die ständevertreter sind
alle die hier sitzen Berlin weiß ich
nicht vertreten bestimmte Institutionen
das sind Lobbyisten wir sind der Partei
muss er wieder aufgestellt so von
Wahlkreis nun ist Mutti Weg mal sehen
wie der März mit dem umgeht aber ich sag
den habe ich immer unterschiedlich
aber ich glaube so aber die Frage den
Fakten bleiben das ist schon selbst in
so Kleinigkeit getragen dass Menschen
die einem anderen Meinung haben schauen
Sie mal ich habe einen dreiviertel Jahr
für ein amerikanisches Magazin die will
Sendung beobachtet Anne Will Fernsehen
in Deutschland
die zwei Drittel davon war niemals
eingeladen ein Wissenschaftler der nicht
die gleiche Meinung das war wie ein
Chorgesang der Tomate
wir haben uns alle lieb erst nach und
nach wurde nach Hamburger eingeladen und
der Bonner also in der Bevölkerung ein
bisschen ich glaube um eine will zu
analysieren brauchen wir gar nicht
sagen
bitte schön Stimmen konsequent
ausgegrenzt nochmal dann waren sie Nazis
lassen Sie uns einfach arrogant sie ist
unerträglich uns einmal mit Hermann gomo
in den Herbst schauen wir bleiben beim
Thema
vor allem Meinung Respekt bei vielen
nach acht auch von Meinung die
vielleicht nicht die eigene sind
deswegen ich bin sehr gespannt was ich
habe